guys just about anybody who plays dota 2
has a love-hate relationship with this
game and a lot of that has to do with
just how powerful some of the heroes are
an alternate term would be broken in
fact some of them are so broken they can
cause even the coolest captain to
completely lose their [ __ ] that's why in
this list we're counting down the top 10
most broken heroes in DotA 2 and look if
you can get through this one without
smashing your keyboard or your monitor
well you're a better man than me coming
in at number ten is phantom assassin of
magenta that's my plate let's not
sugarcoat it guys this heroes design is
completely rng based and while she is
one of the most infuriating heroes to
play against she's also one of the
easiest to play when did it become okay
for her dagger to crit again and don't
tell the next one in their sights they
get salty out onto him but before the
pops gets his kill an Illidan lives with
the hit site for a dagger while Bala
strike you want to get it it's not
pointed up the turn he's gonna be able
to walk away from let me get across seal
Illidan thanks
oh you can't stop this man
the store yeah okay that's fair
next up at number nine is everyone's
favorite pain-in-the-ass
Ricky seriously whose bright idea was it
to give this guy passive inves cloaked
and dad and listen before you say
anything I know he hasn't picked often
in Pro play but do you think anyone in
my pubs buys detection this [ __ ] is not
by invisibility may as well be
invulnerable idli for the spring parka
solar kill universe diffuser plate
yes chef all-stars jump over burka he's
talking you from the from the church the
trainees get the kill he solos universe
and maybe now he goes home on ember
spirit will come in another fuse a fly
shot Barbic has himself a double kill
next up at number eight is storm spirit
oh you a stall must mean now this hero
can do some seriously broken [ __ ] with a
large pool of mana don't believe me just
take a look at how all bad times the
regen from is expiring Aegis with a
massive zip across the map almost wiping
the entire enemy team in the process any
newcomer to dota would say that that's
absolutely broken but the truth is crazy
broken hero mechanics are exactly what
makes this game so amazing and equally
as frustrating what you're gonna do what
you're gonna do in this storm comes for
you keep some attack speed the kid
self-destructing their way to number 7
is everybody's favorite demolition
experts
my god it's turkey we're to start with
this freaking annoying broken character
the constant paranoia when walking
through a jungle infested with landmines
combined with the fact that almost every
game lasts over an hour is truly trauma
inducing little did they know I was
baking so please for the sake of
everyone's mental health leave techies
for certified professionals only
or don't
[Music]
coming in at number six is the hero of
choice for account boosters everywhere
of course we're talking about meepo
downtown nobody in the right hands this
hero can look as if they had cheats on
the entire game and with the ability to
farm multiple areas of the map at the
same time no other hero can level up as
fast unless your team is coordinated and
shutting him down you're probably in for
a loss the pros of trouble countering a
good meepo player there's gonna be no
respect fan so long on that little pink
minor I am so excited
[Music]
at the halfway point on our list is
Punch Ferrari now Pudge had a huge role
in shaping the dota 2 community and
later became one of the most popular
heroes of all time starting with this
one
broken mechanic despite being fixed
Pudge continues to terrorize the pub
scene and has even brought out every now
and then in competitive games to wreak
some havoc Oh
we were not blessed last TI with any
sort of Pudge this time wings do us the
honor here he heads the arrow bank bench
and then he leaves him Kenny Cobras blue
she's a patoot baby's gonna come to
resolution I think at the buckle fetch
them up that goes ship blink actually
dodges it's narrowly the timing wasn't
there now mister he's in trouble
alright sighs looking for a second kill
he's gonna get it nice pickup by the PUD
our next year old has two separate
Ultimates deals an insane amount of
magic damage and has an ability that
makes her untargetable sounds broken
right that's because it is and it's why
dark willow finds her way in at number
four on our list is God creatures all
killed a puck I forgot why I hate to
this dark you look so much like bubs
icefrog please fix this [ __ ] terrorize
terribly can receive all the damage that
dark willow has to offer
what about zeros you straight kill them
seriously how is the support allowed to
solo kill a carry like that there goes
the chances for infamous
rolling his way into the top three is
Earth Spirit this hero was a nightmare
for icefrog to balance and it took over
two years for it to become pickable in
pro play easily the old turnaround like
that right there I feel like it's a
perfect microcosm for the state of this
game for Navi Oh immersion he did the
play I caught one seen that one before
he might not be the most popular hero in
lower MMR brackets but let's be honest
players like Jer axe can make him look
straight up broken okay oh my god oh I
thought that was just a cute play or
something he straight-up executed oh
dude
taking me runner-up spot on our list is
peggle ear
the Honorable don't a bundler it's your
service now look guys even if you're a
huge pango fan you have to admit that
certain elements of his design are just
plain broken the fact that his
swashbuckle can proc attack modifiers
like skull basher is just ridiculous and
fnatic capture another already finding
three here is absolutely huge and what's
with the 17% chance to silence and
disarm get rid of lucky shot icefrog I'm
begging you this hero was literally
broken back when he was released in 2016
which is why we're crowning Monkey King
as dota 2's most broken hero don't look
so surprised human my arrival was full
toned the life steal from his Jingu was
calculated before taking into account
enemy armor values
[Music]
the most portrayed I've ever seen
[Music]
and the game did get low priority fun
experiment to know how broken our hair
is peg we learn that is very broken then
you need to fix this [ __ ] right now
thankfully this was patched almost
immediately but other broken took his
[Music]
ultimate easy wings that look for that
one too
looks like very violent another ten now
guys as tilting as this list was I know
some of you are already planning to hit
up soloqueue but before you do give this
video a like subscribe to the channel
and let me know in the comments below
what's your most hated hero to play
against in a pub is and why it's techies
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]